what is your advice to a young person  who wants to pursue screenwriting i  would say outside of writing which  i mean write write write write as much  as you can which is really difficult  writing is hard  and i would say  to the subject of writing uh  don't don't judge your drafts right away  don't don't tell yourself oh it's dumb i  don't like it and throw it away really  get it in in front of people have  readings is a really easy way  to just hear it out loud and kind of get  it outside of your own head and i would  say other than that make your own direct  your own short films or anything  because i think screenwriting is so much  you know it's always a blueprint for the  movie and i think  directing what you've written is is a  good litmus test to see if it's if it's  working